FEMALE SPEAKER: Hello, everyone.
Welcome, fellow
Googlers and guests.
I am delighted to
introduce to you
today an extremely inspiring,
thoughtful, and genuine person,
the chairman and CEO
of The Container Store,
and the author of
"Uncontainable," Kip Tindell.
Kip has been the helm
of The Container Store
since its stores opened
in Dallas in 1978.
This is the first store
that was devoted solely
to organizational
and storage products.
The Container Store has
stores nationwide now
and a thriving website.
But for Kip, the goal has never
been growth for growth's sakes,
but rather to adhere
to the company's
value-based foundation
principles, which
center around an employee-first
culture, superior customer
service, and strict
merchandising.
In November 2013 under
Kip's leadership,
The Container Store
became a public company.
The primary reason
again for this being
to get more stock into
the hands of employees,
to maximize the autonomy
for the company's culture
and management team and to
have a more visible stage
to create a conscious
company that
inspires others to emulate.
Kip is also very
actively involved
in the community, dedicating
time and resources
to the Salesmanship
Club of Dallas,
serving on the board
of Whole Foods Market.
He is also the first vice
chairman of the board,
chairman of finance
committee, and treasurer
of the National
Retail Federation.
And last, but certainly not
least, he is passionately
involved as a leader in
Conscious Capitalism, Inc.,
which is a community
of like-minded business
thought and academic leaders who
are working to elevate humanity
through a conscious
approach to business.
And before Kip begins
telling us about his book,
we have a short video to watch.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-How do you build a business
where everyone can thrive?
By simultaneously creating
value for everyone involved.
For us, that starts
with our employees.
-Everything that
I do and don't do
matters and affects
someone around me.
And when you feel that kind of
responsibility, going to work
is exciting.
I can't wait to get up
and get my day started.
That's what I love about
working at The Container Store.
I don't just sell products.
I solve problems by helping
our customers get organized,
which I know can
improve their lives.
I can really focus
on helping them,
because I get the communication,
training, and support I need
from the company, my managers
and team, I absolutely love--
-Walking into the store.
No matter what my
day's been like,
I can always find a little
bit of calm to take home.
The employees are so
happy and helpful,
you can't help but smile.
-And let me tell you, my kids
notice when I'm less stressed.
When I can find what I'm
looking for, I have more energy
and I can get everyone
out the door on time.
-The Container Store
is more like a--
- --friend than a company.
I'm not just a vendor to them.
We're partners in success.
They looked beyond the fact that
I was just starting my business
and they saw the potential
in my product and in me.
Because of our
partnership, my business
has grown tremendously.
We've hired more people,
developed new products,
and even taken on a new factory.
Together--
- --we've impacted
so many lives.
Our unique partnership
over the years
has impacted the way
thousands of people
think about their minds--
increasing creativity,
organizing their minds, and
increasing their capacity
to think smarter.
Our connection with
The Container Store--
- --has helped us support
many conscious businesses.
Their commitment to their
foundation principles,
employee-first culture,
and conscious capitalism
is not just marketing spin.
It's making a difference.
The idea that you can make
business decisions based
on love and still
be highly profitable
is gaining momentum
and credibility.
And profits aren't a bad thing.
They're what give
businesses the ability
to take better care
of their employees
and give more to
their communities.
It's not altruism.
It's capitalism being done
in a conscious way that
ensures everyone--
- --All the customers--
- --the employees--
- --all the vendors--
- --the entire community--
- --and the shareholders--
- --can all thrive together.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
FEMALE SPEAKER:
Now if you can all
help me in extending a warm
welcome to Kip Tindell.
[APPLAUSE]
KIP TINDELL: Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Well, that's what we're trying
to do at The Container Store
is a create a business
where everyone thrives.
And we spend more time working
than any other waking endeavor.
And so I just
think it's probably
the best thing you can
do with all those hours
that you spend working,
create a business where
everyone thrives.
And that means very much
in the conscious capitalist
stakeholder model, the employee
thrives, the community thrives,
the vendor thrives, the
shareholder thrives.
Everyone associated with
the business thrives.
How many of you have shopped
at The Container Store?
OK, that's pretty good.
We have to work on you too.
Well, we began in 1978 with one
tiny little 1600-square-foot
store in Dallas, Texas, with
a whopping $35,000 in capital.
And somehow we knew--
I don't know how,
but somehow we
knew that-- I mean,
people think of The Container
Store as saving space,
getting you organized.
But what I think
we're really doing
is giving our customers
the gift of organization.
You really have no choice
but to be reasonably
well-organized in
your life if you're
going to accomplish half of
what you want to accomplish.
Something as simple as getting
two children ready for school
in the morning is either
a nightmare or a pleasure,
depending upon how organized
you are and they are.
Traveling is so much
simpler if you're
reasonably well-organized.
So I really do feel like we're
giving the gift of an organized
life to our customers.
It was interesting
starting the business.
I mean, my dad, who's like, he's
kind of a Texas oil man, right?
He was like, you're
going to open
a store that sells empty boxes?
I mean, he was really
concerned about all that.
But that's not really the
target customer at all.
So it all worked out.
We run our company on seven
foundation principles,
which I won't be able to go
into all in this little talk.
But they're all available
online at our blog,
whatwestandfor.com.
And these seven
foundation principles
are identical to
the four tenants
of conscious capitalism.
And we've been operating
that way since 1978.
We just didn't know to call it
conscious capitalism back then.
And so they're
simple, almost corny,
"do unto others" type things
that everybody agrees on.
How many of you
don't really agree
with that "do unto
others" thing?
You think that's a bad idea?
So see, everybody agrees
with these simple things.
One of them is Andrew
Carnegie's statement.
The great industrialist
Andrew Carnegie
was laying on his deathbed
and attributed all
his business success to the
one credo, the one guiding
light that fill the other guy's
basket to the brim-- making
money then becomes
an easy proposition.
Fill the other guy's basket to
the brim-- making money then
becomes an easy proposition.
That's the exact
opposite of what
people are raised to believe,
that business is somehow
a zero sum game, where someone
has to lose in order for you
to win.
And so that one
foundation principle,
fill the other guy's
basket, has us creatively
crafting mutually beneficial
relationships with our vendors.
And being able to
compete with the giant,
mass merchant
retailers in America,
because we can't beat them
on volume necessarily.
But we can beat
them on relationship
synergistic win-win, fill the
other guy's basket relationship
with these vendors.
And you become your
vendor's favorite customer.
And you don't have to beat
up your vendor to get ahead.
It's far better to creatively
craft that mutually beneficial
relationship, which is only
limited by your imagination
and how much you can learn
about each other's businesses.
And then you form this
synergistic relationship
that is immensely more
profitable than just
the old power struggle,
the tug and back and forth
of trying to sort of
beat up the vendor.
And it's much more enjoyable.
If you look at
the companies that
are dominating their
niches-- and Google
is a great example-- Southwest
Airlines, Whole Foods,
Costco-- they're very
good at those synergistic
relationships.
That's where actually
more money is made.
Conscious capitalism
is not a sacrifice.
Conscious capitalism actually
makes you more profitable than
if you were trying to
do it the other way.
And that's why I think
that eventually, people
like John Mackey,
the Whole Foods guy,
and I can quit trying
to spread the word
about conscious
capitalism, because I think
a good capitalist is
going to eventually adopt
that methodology which
is most successful.
And it's kind of a movement.
And it's kind of beginning
to happen like that.
Skepticism is vanishing.
Much to my delight
and surprise, when
we did our IPO roadshow, the
largest institutional investors
on Wall Street, all they
really wanted to talk about
was conscious capitalism and
the quirky, yummy culture
of The Container Store.
I thought when I tried
to talk about culture,
they would roll their eyes
and get impatient and think
"Kumbaya" and all that.
But I mean, skepticism
is vanishing on this.
And it's fun to give a
presentation at Google
because Google is a
great example of it.
So I encourage you to read
about the foundation principles.
They're simple.
You can read about them on
the blog, what we stand for.
And they were created
as a means to the end.
We have 6,000 employees.
We don't want to be
6,000 yahoos going
in 6,000 different directions.
So we agree on the ends, like
fill the other guy's basket
to the brim.
And then everybody's enabled
to choose their own means
to the end.
I don't think I'm smart enough.
No one's smart enough
to tell that many people
how to handle any
given situation.
Because life's too situational.
And certainly retail
is too situational.
So that unharnesses
everybody to use
their own individual
creative genius
to figure out how
to get to that end.
And you'll hear things like,
well, why do we do it that way?
Well, that's because of the
Andrew Carnegie thing, the fill
the other guy's
basket to the brim.
And what's remarkable
about that,
and it kind of
surprised me how true
it is, even though he never
told all these people how
to handle a particular
circumstance, just
liberating everybody
to agree on these ends
and choose their own means
causes a circumstance that
arises in the Miami store
to be handled miraculously,
the same as it is in
the Seattle store.
People are people.
They're using individual means,
but the ends are the same.
Does that makes sense?
I mean, it's just the old
means to the end thing.
I think it's oppressive
to try to tell people
how to get to the end.
Let them figure out--
let them be themselves.
Let them be their own
beautiful, unique personalities.
And then just kind
of agree on the ends.
Conscious capitalism is
something I'm passionate about.
Weirdly and oddly
enough, John Mackey,
the quirky, wonderful founder
and CEO of Whole Foods and I
were actually college roommates
at University of Texas.
It's just bizarre.
And then we both
went off and started
these conscious capitalist
retail businesses.
We saw each other a little bit,
but not that much after school.
We were so busy
being entrepreneurs
and growing our businesses.
And after about 20
years, we got together
for this really extensive,
almost all-day-long Time
Magazine article.
And we were rolling
on the floor,
laughing hysterically at
how identical our business
philosophies have become, even
though we hadn't-- I mean,
that's not what we
talked about in college.
You know what we talked
about in college,
and it wasn't
conscious capitalism.
It was girls.
It wasn't retail.
And so many identical things
that we thought no one
believed or no one thought
and it was just hysterical.
And that article is still out
there on the internet-- Time
Magazine with John
Mackey and Kip Tindell.
The four tenets of conscious
capitalism-- number one,
you have a higher
purpose as a business.
You have a higher purpose
than just profit or just
making money for your business.
I don't know any
entrepreneurs-- I
don't think I've ever
met an entrepreneur that
said the reason they
did what they did
was to make a lot of money.
Doctors don't say
the reason I became
a doctor was to make
a lot of money, right?
I mean, it's you have a higher
purpose besides just profits.
That's one of the four tenets
of conscious capitalism.
The other is
conscious leadership.
Conscious leadership-- I think
CEOs get too much credit.
They're kind of in
this celebrity culture.
I think they're a
little overglamorized.
It's really the
people behind them,
people around them,
the management team
and the part-time
worker in the store that
really makes the
business what it is.
But with conscious capitalism,
that person who is in that top
role and the top management
team needs to really genuinely
believe, in their heart and
soul, in conscious capitalism,
or it cannot and will not
happen in that organization.
Because there's too many
forces to push against it.
It has to be OK to behave
like that thoroughly.
And it really helps for
that individual leader
to understand and embody
the whole servant leadership
aspect of leadership,
and not be particularly
in it for themselves.
What really helps is
if they're kind of
pretty high on Maslow's
hierarchy of needs.
It's hard to manage that way if
you're cold or hungry or lonely
or still trying to prove
to your dead father
that you're a great businessman.
You know?
I mean, deep-seated
insecurities get
in the way of that
type of leadership.
Servant leadership
is a key component
of conscious capitalism.
I think it sums it up very well.
And one thing I've
learned is I used
to just think we
needed the smartest
person to take that
big, important job.
And I love intelligence,
and you look for that.
But the social IQ is
even more important
than the intellectual IQ--
something I've really learned.
And so having those
qualities, those understanding
and being good at nurturing
and communication, social IQ,
being calmly self-confident but
in a very servant leadership,
giving way, so that
you're not-- you
can't give if you're that needy.
You can't be a
good leader and you
can't do much for
the world around you
if you don't have
anything to give.
So that type of conscious
leadership's the second point
that I think is so important
in conscious leadership.
The other's a stakeholder model.
And I love the
stakeholder model.
And Ed Freeman at University
of Virginia Darden School
of Business is credited
with having created
the conscious capitalism
stakeholder model.
You're optimizing the needs
of all the stakeholders
of the business.
Let's see-- Milton Friedman,
the famous economist, once said,
the only reason a
corporation exists
is to maximize the return
of the shareholder.
And we're like, you
know what, Milton?
I know you won a Nobel
Prize and everything.
With all due respect,
at The Container Store,
we actually put
the employee first.
And if you take
better care-- I mean,
if you really take better care
of the employee than anybody
else, she's going
to really take care
of the customer
than anybody else.
And of those two people are
ecstatic-- let's face it,
if your employees
are ecstatic, you're
getting remarkable productivity.
If your customers
are ecstatic, you're
getting remarkable sales.
So if those two
people are ecstatic,
your shareholders are
going to be ecstatic too.
So I'm not sure we
really refute or disagree
with Milton Friedman on the end.
We just have a different
means to the end.
And it's more joyful
to do it that way.
And if you myopically focus
only on the shareholder,
the magic is lost and very
often the employees are unhappy
and the customers are
unhappy and the shareholder's
going to be unhappy too.
So the stakeholder model allows
us to put they employee first
and to never rest while we
try to see how much more we
can do for that employee.
And I can't wait for my
tour of Google headquarters
here in a minute.
I can see so much of that here.
It's a joy to see.
It really-- I mean,
of course, I love it.
It's so great.
And like Google, The
Container Store's
been on the Fortune
100 Best Companies
To Work For in America list for,
in our case, 15 straight years.
We were number one
twice, number two twice.
I think Google was
number one at least once.
It's a never-ending game.
You're constantly
trying to see what
else you can do
for the employee.
As a result, after 36 years
I think our employee morale
is the highest it's
ever been right now.
One of the reasons
we went public
was to get more stock in
the hands of employees.
It's standard
operating procedure
to do options when
you're public.
When you're private,
you have to depend
upon your private partners
believing enough and getting
stock in the hands of
employees to dilute themselves.
I've always believed
in doing that.
My wife, Sharon, is
our chief merchant.
And we were lucky enough to
get a bunch of stock in 1978
in this company that turned
out to be kind of a fairy tale
success story.
And so we can dilute ourselves
in order to get people,
like these two wonderful vice
presidents here, more stock.
And I think the happiest, most
devoted employee in the world
still does better if they
own some of the company.
But if you're private,
you have to-- see,
people don't understand
that it's better
to own 50% of a dollar
than 100% of a nickel.
And your beautiful
private investors usually
have some lawyer or
spouse or accountant
that really won't
let them do that.
So that's one of the major
reasons we went public.
Also in that
stakeholder model, you
have the vendor stakeholder.
You can't tell the difference
between a vendor and a employee
at The Container Store.
I love elevating
the relationships
that we have with
these manufacturers.
We really are--
somebody gets the lowest
price in the country.
Somebody gets the last
pallet of a very hot item
that holiday season.
We create products
with these vendors.
This guy's the best at wire.
This guy's the best at wood.
OK, let's create the wood in
Estonia, where all the wood is.
And the same people
for 5, 15, 25 years,
you're creating products
that nobody else carries
that's exclusive to
The Container Store.
And these relationships
build, and they
become your best friend.
You travel the world
with them and you
create product that is so fun.
I mean, we get excited
about silly things.
We get excited about having--
we just recently created
the world's absolutely best
shoe boxes and sweater boxes.
I mean, it was ecstasy to us.
It was just fun.
But you pick these people
that are the most talented,
manufacturing certain
types of products.
And then since The Container
Store has its finger
closer to the pulse of
the consumer than most
manufacturers, you can
create great product
that the big mass
merchants don't have.
You have no reason to exist if
you're selling the same thing
everybody else is.
And that's creatively
crafting a mutually beneficial
relationship with the vendor.
And then when you
do well, when you
have very high
financial performance,
you can do wonderful
things for the community.
Communities go out of
their way to do anything
they can with The
Container Store.
This one wants our
headquarters in its town,
because they really see us
as embodying family values,
and they do that.
So they make it impossible
for us to not locate that
in that community.
It's so nice when
the communities
that you serve, with
open arms help you.
And in fact, conscious
capitalism what it really does
is it causes the universe
to conspire to assist you.
And it's a lot easier to
be successful in business
when the universe is
conspiring to assist you
than it is if people are
laying awake at night trying
to figure out how
to get back at you.
And it makes life so pleasant
to be loved rather than hated.
I think the universe
conspires to assist
an individual or a company
when it behaves this way.
The fourth tenet of
conscious capitalism
is a conscious culture.
The culture drives the
value of the business.
I believe the culture
drives the value of Google.
It certainly drives the
value of The Container Store.
Much to my happiness,
I discovered
that most of the institutional
investors on Wall Street
accept the notion that
the culture drives
the value of the business.
Drucker said that
culture eats strategy
for breakfast in the morning.
And it's really true.
And so those are the four
tenets of conscious capitalism.
And they happen to be exactly
the same thing as our seven
foundation principles,
which you're
going to go onto
whatwestandfor.com to learn
more about, I hope.
So capitalism has a
public relations problem.
It really does.
I mean, I'm a capitalist.
If you ask a bunch
of millennial people,
or even a bunch of baby
boomers whether they
want to be a capitalist,
most of them will say no.
You ask them if they want
to be an entrepreneur,
they'll all say yes.
But they don't want
to be a capitalist.
But capitalism is actually good.
When I talk about
this, it makes me
sound like some kind of a
libertarian or something.
Mackey is, but I'm not.
I'm kind of a moderate Democrat.
But capitalism is the most
efficient system ever devised
to move goods and
services and get them
where they needed to be to
the betterment of humanity.
Communism didn't work.
200 million people died, right?
Socialism isn't
working that well.
200 years ago, a
little more than 85%
of the world's population
lived on $1 a day.
200 years ago, including
in this country--
most people lived on $1 a day.
Now only 16% of the
world lives on $1 a day.
That type of abject
poverty is certainly
moving in a good trend.
And by the time-- the
age group in this room,
by the time you're at the end of
the lifespan of your children,
that number is thought to
be-- will be like 1/100 of 1%,
it's really thought
will be that negligible.
Bill Clinton is running
around the world giving
a speech that's
roughly entitled,
Charity Won't Save the World.
Business Will.
Business is so
much more powerful
than all the nonprofits
and charities of the world
that if we could harness
the good of business
to make the world and the
planet better than it's been,
not only would those
businesses do better,
but the world would be quite
a bit better off as well.
So that's really the power
of conscious capitalism.
And if you look at-- John
Mackey and Raj Sisodia
co-wrote the book
"Conscious Capitalism."
Great book.
You should read "Conscious
Capitalism" if you haven't.
I bet some of you have.
Raj is on our board at The
Container Store-- college
professor, big rock star,
international college
professor.
He did an exhaustive
study that is so helpful
to have of all the companies,
the public companies
in America, that have--
including Google-- that
have been public for
a good long while.
And what he discovered is that
those companies outperformed
the S&P Index 14 to 1
over the last 15 years.
I mean, 14 to 1.
Are you kidding me?
That's 1400-- it's not 20%
better or 80% percent better.
It's 1,400% better.
And for a long time, 15 years.
And those companies like
Google and Whole Foods
and Southwest Airlines--
The Container Store
is not on the list yet.
It's in the book.
He's studied us
too, but we haven't
been public for long enough
to be on that part of it.
We've been public for
just under a year.
So if all you really want
to do is make as much money
as humanly possible,
as rapidly as possible,
I would submit to you that
conscious capitalism's the way
to do it.
But further than
that, it enriches
your lives and the
lives of the people
you do business with hugely
while it's doing that.
No wonder the universe conspires
to help companies like that.
Everybody's proud of the
way they behave themselves.
Everybody's proud of
the fact that they
help their communities.
If a company nurtures
its employees-- certainly
seems to be going on here--
makes them feel valued,
elevates their self-esteem
rather than tearing down
their self-esteem,
pays them well,
lets them be themselves at
work, rewards the creativity
that comes from them
being themselves,
spends money to train
and develop them,
makes them thrive, that
employee goes home at night
and he treats his family
differently-- better.
Treats his golden
retriever better.
Treats the guy at the
7-Eleven on the way home
totally differently.
Way up on Maslow--
he's is a fulfilled,
generous but
self-confident human being
that behaves differently.
And when companies do that,
when organizations do that,
they're just as attractive
and they're just
as better able to help everyone
and everything around them.
And so that's what the
foundation principles do.
That's what conscious
capitalism does.
That's when everybody's
thriving is when you sort of get
that action, you get
that type of thing.
I used to hate it
when it happened,
but I have employees
say things like, kept
working at The Container Store
has made me a better father.
I'm like, oh, my God.
Don't say that.
It's embarrassing.
I mean, like, really?
Then they go into
telling me why.
Or at company functions,
happens all the time, somebody
will stand up and
say, my husband
is a better father and
a better spouse because
of the foundational principles
of working at The Container
Store.
And it's like, you never
get used to hearing that.
And it is embarrassing,
but it is true.
And so I think businesses
just to remember
that every single
employee worldwide
is somebody's
precious child that's
been nurtured and
developed by parents.
And now we have a lot of
control over their lives,
because you spend most of
your waking hours working.
And people-- it's
probably wrong,
but we put too much of
our self-worth in what we
do at work.
Friends and family
are more important,
but our self-esteem has a
great deal to do with work.
So an oppressive workplace,
an oppressive employer
is really bad for the human
spirit and human psyche.
And a good one is
really, really good.
Part of it is understanding the
essence of the human spirit.
People don't want to come
to work and goof off and do
as little as possible.
They want to come to work and
do great things with people
they admire and love.
They love to work
with great people
and then go home
at night, feeling
wonderful about what
they've accomplished.
And so a good boss recognizes
that and nurtures and develops
that.
A bad boss is
someone that thinks
that people don't
want to do much.
And then they
treat them that way
and then you kind of
reap what you sow.
Another important
thing is that people
love to work with
people that are great.
At The Container Store,
another foundation principle
is one equals three.
We only hire great people.
I know Google does
the same thing.
How delightful it is to be
able to work with people that
are wonderful, that you
think are wonderful.
In fact, I think it's one the
most important aspects of being
a great place to
work, that you get
to work-- if we
started a golf team
and we had Phil Mickelson
on the golf team,
don't you think we'd
feel better about being
on that team than
if he wasn't there?
It's like, wow!
It's really great.
So that's something we really
pay a lot of attention to.
One equals three.
One great person can easily
do the business productivity
of three good people.
We don't have an HR department.
Our head of
recruiting understands
that it's her job to
make sure the rest of us
bring all of our friends and
relatives in that are great.
We don't have any rules against
family or relationships.
Sharon and I are
married, so it's mayhem.
People get married.
They date, they whatever.
That's fine.
People bring in their relatives.
I mean, you know which of your
cousins are great and which
ones aren't.
So I think that's how
you find great people,
is finding people you
care about and you know.
A pretty good
summation of what we
do to try to make everybody
thrive, what I believe Google
does, what conscious
capitalism companies do,
is the wake thing.
W-A-K-E, like a boat's wake.
Your wake and my
wake-- your wake
is so much bigger and more
powerful than you think it is.
It's really an
interesting message.
Everybody wildly underestimates
the power of their wake.
And even the most arrogant
person you know wildly
underestimates the
power of their wake.
My favorite movie's
probably, corny
as it is, "It's a
Wonderful Life."
Because the whole
movie shows one guy,
George Bailey, the
incredible power of his wake.
And he believed that
his savings and loan
had such an amazing
impact on Bedford Falls.
You're like that.
We're all like that.
Isn't nice to know
that everything
you do and everything
you do not do
has such an impact on the people
around you and your business.
So I think that a person
that's mindful of their wake
behaves differently and
behaves a lot better.
And other people find her to be
more honorable, easier to love,
exciting to be around.
An organization where everybody
is mindful of its wake
is the same way.
That's an unassailable
business advantage.
People want to work
for that company.
They want to shop.
Consumers vote with
their pocketbook.
You want to be a
vendor to that company.
It's such an honor to
be a vendor of Google,
or vendor of Container Store.
If you're a vendor of
The Container Store,
then everybody that wants to
do storage and organization
sees that.
Then they want your product,
because The Container Store
leads that category.
So the power of your
wake-- I think wake
is a really good summation of
what conscious capitalism is
all about, just being
mindful of the impact of what
we do as an organization.
So it's creating
a business where
everyone associated
with it thrives.
The stakeholder model
can go to-- I've
talked to Ed Freeman about this.
And it can be your employee's,
child's, school's, vendor's,
that ripple effect can go out
so that the way that you deal
with that stakeholder is
impacted way out there.
It's really a beautiful thought.
I mean, if you think
the power of your wake's
is not just dramatically
more, just think
about the ripple effect
of things like that.
But conscious capitalism,
our foundation principles,
creating a yummy, quirky
culture where everybody thrives
and everybody can be themselves.
People join the company
and they never leave.
We have turnover
of less than 10%
in a retail industry that has an
average turnover of over 100%.
Even though we have one
ex-employee that just joined us
here that used to work
for The Container Store
now works for Google.
But we still love her.
She's great.
She's part of that
single digit turnover.
But I love retail.
I love The Container Store.
We're so nuts that my
wife and I are still
working 70 or 80 hours a
week after 36 years of it.
But we're doing what we love.
I really do believe that
the true artist of life
blurs the distinction
between work and play.
Vendors become friends.
Creating a new product is
more fun than playing golf.
You're like Monet
painting the water lilies.
You're doing what
you want to do.
And I think that's when
you can do great things
and leave the world a better
place than you found it
and have an impact
on your employees
and your stakeholders' lives.
And it's really fun just
sharing some of these thoughts
with you here at Google.
I'm getting ready to get
a tour of your campus
now, which I can't wait for.
And I thank you for being here.
We have a few
minutes for questions
if anybody has some questions.
So the question is, how do
you deal with it when you're
in a business environment, in a
work culture where you believe
in the concepts of conscious
capitalism or whatnot,
but the people you're
working with do not.
They look at you like you're
from a different planet
because they really don't
believe in the stuff.
First of all, that's changing.
That's becoming less
and less frequent,
but it's certainly
still out there.
And I think sticking
to your principles
in the face of all that
is still important, sort
of almost leading by example.
We've had a lot of influence on
getting all the best business
schools in the country to begin
teaching conscious capitalism.
And I think it's important
for people, when they get out
of their MBA program, to
understand that business is not
a zero sum game.
It's not a zero sum game, and
that's beginning to change.
It's not glacial.
It's happening pretty quickly.
The skepticism that I see
about conscious capitalism
is a small fraction of what
it was even five years ago.
And these models, like Google
and The Container Store
are helping to persuade people.
It's very different-- it's
very difficult if you're
working at a company
that just refuses
to understand it or believe it.
It's easier if you're
leading that company.
Then you can do
something about it.
And I would tend to
say maybe that culture
wasn't the right
culture for you.
Maybe you could
find a company that
behaved a little more that
way and you might flourish
and be happier in that culture.
Or, you can doggedly try to
turn it around from within.
I think that's the--
leaving the world better
place than you found it,
you just might succeed.
I've seen that
happen a few times.
And really working on the
leadership of the business
to change their
values and attitudes
is what's most important.
I think there are some
really good stories about how
store managers
were always asking
what their most important
responsibility was.
And it wasn't sales.
It wasn't one equals
three great people.
It was managing the values
and attitudes of people
that they lead.
And I think you do that to a
great extent as a co-worker
too.
It's really fun to work
with people that you admire
and who are great.
You can do so much more, as
we were talking about earlier.
So I hope that answers
it a little bit.
It's a tough question.
But we're succeeding
in getting it taught.
We're succeeding in
getting countless business
organizations,
entrepreneurs to start out
building businesses that way.
When you start a business,
you get to kind of model
the culture around
your own belief system.
It's a ridiculous privilege.
What a joy and what a
responsibility and what
a privilege.
When you manage somebody, you
have this huge responsibility
to where you have a lot
of impact on their lives.
And so then you can do it.
As a worker, as a
coworker, you're
not quite as powerful for that.
But I like to thank you can have
some influence, some growing
influence.
Patience is probably important.
But I can see you doing that.
Any other questions,
or another question?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: When you started
the company, your store,
did you-- obviously the
idea of conscious capitalism
is something you
established from day one.
But did you start with
knowing that you wanted
to start a company that
had that kind of culture,
or did you start with the
idea [INAUDIBLE] same time?
KIP TINDELL: I was always
really interested in philosophy.
I wanted to major in
philosophy in school
and my dad said no, you
can't major in philosophy
or you'll have to
pay your own way.
So I majored in English, which
is exactly the same thing.
And the Whole Foods
guy, John Mackey,
did major in philosophy.
And we did talk a lot
about that-- idealistic 19-
or 21-year-olds talking about
Kierkegaard and Nietzsche
and all of that--
it was a blast.
What we do has absolutely
nothing to do with religion,
but I did go to Jesuit
High School in Dallas.
And we had a lot
of young priests
at the time that were extremely
into existential philosophy.
And they taught me a lot.
And I read everything
and I kept a little file
of all the greatest thoughts
I had ever heard of or been
taught or read or even
thought of myself.
And 10 years into the business,
we opened a store in Houston
at the corner of Post,
Oak and Westheimer.
And we were doing three or four
times what we expected to do.
It was mayhem.
We just couldn't
keep up with it.
And people we were
hiring weren't right.
The store scared me.
It wasn't our-- so we had a
big meeting with all the staff
at the store manager's house.
And I was trying
to figure out what
to do to teach them who we
were, what we stood for.
See, before that you
could take somebody out
to have Mexican food and
a couple of margaritas
and explain everything
to them in one evening.
And now it had to be
something more formalized.
We were getting
too big for that.
And I reached into that
file I was describing
and brought out the seven
foundation principles-- or six,
we've added one since then.
And the one we've added is
communication is leadership.
Leadership and communication
are the same thing,
which is a wonderful,
wonderful thought.
That's what leadership is.
Communication can pretty
well solve anything.
own And so leadership
and communication
are the same thing.
And they went crazy.
They loved it.
I was so afraid to tell
them, because these
were my most personally
held philosophies.
And I think your life
philosophy should
be your business philosophy.
See, people think that you
can have a different code
of conduct in business
than you can personal.
And that's ridiculous.
So what do you gotta do, treat
all the people you do business
with worse than the people--
well, you have to understand,
it's just businesses.
Like, no I don't
understand that at all.
I mean, you can't-- so we were
very mindful of all this from
the very beginning.
We talked about it a lot.
It's just who we
were and what we are
and then that's how
it became formalized.
And now, it is so
hard to believe
that people are teaching
it in business schools.
We have employees that
say, my favorite course
in my MBA program
was the semester
we spent on The Container
Store's business philosophies.
And I'm like, what?
That's what that book
is, "Uncontainable."
"Uncontainable: How Passion,
Commitment and Conscious
Capitalism Built a Business
Where Everyone Thrives."
So the employees of
The Container Store
have been wanting
this book to be
written for many, many years.
They're proud of our
business philosophies.
And I was like, oh, we
don't have time for that.
We have to create
more sweater boxes.
We have to get that store
opened in Salt Lake.
We're opening a new store
in Salt Lake Saturday.
And that will be number 68.
But Casey Shilling,
our vice president
of public relations and I
have been working together
for 17 years.
And she was a huge help.
The book would never
happened without her.
Another guy, Paul Keegan,
helped me write it.
So I was standing on
the shoulders of giants.
I had two people forcing me
to write it, to find the time.
And we did it together.
So it's only been
out about a week.
The reviews have been
embarrassingly fabulous.
And I'm getting all
kinds of emails and calls
from people that have-- it's
weird when you write a book.
People that you love and
people that you admire
have read your book and they
know all this personal stuff
about you.
So you have these
remarkable conversations.
And it's a lot of fun.
Yes, sir?
So two questions.
I mean, given the
business climate,
would do create a business
like The Container Store
again today?
Yes, and I'll go into why.
And the first
question was, I guess
I can only remember
one question at a time.
AUDIENCE: How do you
solve capitalism's--
KIP TINDELL: How do we solve
capitalism's public relations
problem?
Well, I mean you're doing it
every day at Google-- Southwest
Airlines.
Herb Kelleher is kind
of a hero of mine.
He's a Southwest
Airlines founder.
And he told me 30
or 35 years ago,
you can build a
better organization.
You can build a better
business organization on love
than you can fear.
And I thought, wow,
who is this guy?
He's the smart guy in Dallas.
He's just awesome.
And so John Mackey, the
Whole Foods guy, and I
talk a lot about
love and business,
about coworkers having
each other's backs
and truly loving the workplace.
And no fear.
And companies like
that, I think,
are building the case for
conscious capitalism every day.
And so I think we're making
a lot of progress on that
and that pretty soon most of the
most talented capitalists will
be able to perceive that
companies they behave like that
make a lot more money
than the ones that don't.
And they have more
joyful stakeholders.
And so it is already becoming
so much more prevalent
than it was five or
eight years ago when
we had these weird little
gatherings outside of Austin,
Texas and started talking about
these strange concepts called
conscious capitalism.
Now you have the Unilever
CEO and these giant business
executives carrying
on about the stuff.
And I think we're
definitely making progress.
Now I forgot the other question.
What was it?
AUDIENCE: Given the business--
KIP TINDELL: Yeah, I
think we'd do it again.
You don't have a chance
with a retail business,
as mass merchant as the
economy is, you would think.
But when you do it this way,
when you create a business
relationship with your
vendor that is your vendor's
favorite business relationship,
and they want to see you win
and they're doing
everything they
can to creatively craft a
synergistic relationship
with you so that you do
better and they do better.
And that's when you start
having a chance against all
the incredible competition,
because most people aren't
doing that.
I don't know what happens once
everybody starts doing that.
Then the little guy would have
a hard time again, I guess.
But in the meantime, this
is a really great way
for smaller entrepreneurs
to do really
well so that it's not just the
giant mass merchants dominating
everything.
And talent's the whole ballgame.
We try so hard to hire only the
very, very, very best people
at whatever endeavor.
Because life's too short not
to do things with excellence.
And it's so thrilling to
do things with excellence.
And then that kind
of self-monitors.
If somebody's kind of floating
along and not really applying
themselves, they're
very unpopular
and they leave after a while.
So I think we could do it again.
It was daunting in 1978.
You couldn't go start
one little retail store
and expect to be able to make
it, much less have everything
evolve how it is.
I mean, I would do that,
because I love retail.
I think it's-- with all the
creativity and all the people
orientation, I think it's the
best profession in the world.
I'm getting ready to be the
chairman of the National Retail
Federation January
1 for two years.
And I'm really looking
forward to that
as the spokesperson for one
in four American workers.
Retail employees, one in
four of America's workers.
So, a big responsibility
and something I'm
really looking forward to.
And I just like being
an entrepreneur.
I couldn't wait to
get out of school
so I could start something.
What would I do if it hadn't
been The Container Store?
I always say, I'd
probably be a fly fishing
guide somewhere in Colorado.
But I don't think so.
Like I say, creating the
world's most perfect sweater box
is a lot more fun than fly
fishing or playing golf.
Although you need to
fly fish sometimes.
And I actually get some of
my best ideas fly fishing.
Because the only thing
you're worried about
is what fly that trout wants.
So it's not an
earth-shaking problem.
It frees up your mind to
think about a lot of things.
My old original
partner, Garrett Boone,
this lady who used to work
with us said we probably
would have gone into furniture.
And I think he would have.
What's ironic is
that I probably would
have gone into some type
of gourmet food thing.
I'm a big foodie.
I was taking courses
at the LBJ School
of Public Affairs
in Austin-- a lot
of grocery stores and stuff.
I was interested in that.
And then it was kind of
funny that John Mackey
went off and did that.
But he actually met a girl
that was really big into that.
That's what converted him.
I never did the
food thing, but I'm
so proud that there's grocery
stores like that in America
now.
Grocery stores in Texas of
that-- New York's always
had a few.
France has them.
But I mean, you get a grocery
store like that in Iowa.
That's quite a contribution.
Plus I think it's probably
increased the life expectancy
of the average American
by five or seven years,
because even someone who's
never set foot in a Whole Foods,
Whole Foods has changed
what the mass merchants sell
in their grocery stores, to
the benefit of everybody.
That's a neat question.
But I do like the
entrepreneur thing.
And I do try to encourage
people to go off and do that.
What's important is that
you do it right away,
as soon as you get out of
school, as you get your MBA
or whatever.
Because once you are
making-- particularly
if you're lucky enough
to, at a young age,
make something like
$150,000 or $200,000 a year
and then you get married
and you have two kids,
you are not going to
go start something.
You have to do it
when you're poor,
when you first get out
of school or whatever.
That's when you have the
best chance of doing it.
I thank you all for being here.
I hope you'll read the
book "Uncontainable."
We're really proud
of it and delighted
that it's off to a great start.
Hope you'll go online and read
about the foundation principles
and thank you for having me.
Thanks.
[APPPLAUSE]